welcome to pi day of 2021 with
for our talk with core and and kevin
uh
core or
core is uh
core is demystifying data at go dry go
data driven where he builds azure data
platforms and implements data use cases
together with their clients
in his talk he will he and kevin will
show one such use case
from enter food and enter food and uh
all right this is your guys times so
i'll pass the mic to you
thanks very much steven welcome
everybody
so uh me and kev are going to talk about
the wisdom of the crowd
amplifying human intelligence
um i'm from gold riven and kevin from
interfood we'll start with introduction
after that we have a um a nice
promotional video which is the end goal
where we built so during this talk and
then after the promotional video we'll
explain how we get there
um to reiterate like i said already i'm
trying to keep an eye on the question
box so there's a question box make sure
you drop it in the question box and not
in the message
in the chat
um we try to keep an eye on them and
answer them during the talk but we have
some room at the end of the talk
to uh discuss those questions so um
enjoy
and
so who are we i'm gonna give
the mic to kevin
yeah thank you cork
so i'm kevin dyson i'm an inter-foods
global analytics manager where i have
responsibility over our global team of
analyst scientists and engineers
i've got a phd ongoing in high
dimensional statistics in leiden
university and also have been a visitor
at stanford this is where that picture
originated from some of you may
recognize
and i've got a background in data
consulting for instance at the united
nations and uh i was in m a finance
before uh before joining this uh this
career data
off the core
thank you kevin uh so like steven said
i'm demystifying data at go data driven
it's a favorite word of mine i don't
like the saying like making
like take away of some of the mystique
behind data
and i think the talk right now we're
going to have today i think it's perfect
example how we do this how we have this
sort of mysterious goal and how we
really worked towards a tangible data
product
um i do this at golden drift and i will
talk more about go to data driven in a
moment i'm data engineer there we also
give training so i do science training
and engineering training i have a
master's in the data science and ai but
i'm an engineer at heart uh i'm active
in the open source community lately
working on the data quality package
called solder spark and also solar sql i
have some commits for dbt and
if you just like generally have a look
at my gita handle
and i'm also part of the python payday
amsterdam committee so i'm a very much
fan of what we do here sharing knowledge
and uh very uh thankful for people
hosting this global
event kevin can you talk about the
influence yeah very briefly uh a few
words about uh but in the food and
actually what uh what has has connected
core and and myself
so interfood is a global dairy trading
company uh in the commodity business
with about 2 billion euros of turnover
which means that that we try to connect
physical supply and demand in dairy
products
for about a million metric tons of
milk equivalents every year every year
so that's there's a lot of logistics and
that's also what you see
in our in our history 50 years of dairy
experience where
firstly we offer services in logistics
but now also we we add other services on
top such as for instance financial price
risk management and we do so for most of
the many
famous food brands in the world so it's
very likely that if you eat a bar of
chocolate there's some some inter-food
dairy in there and the same holes for
for your ice cream
now as i mentioned some of the services
that that we try to offer to our clients
are not only in the physical product but
also in the financial space and this has
to do with the fact that dairy commodity
prices are very very volatile and it
also means why data is so important in
the dairy business
and as you see here this is volatility
over over the past years which which is
actually fairly substantial these are
not bitcoins this is just the dairy
futures
um and that is also what has connected
the interfood to uh to an expert partner
such as go data driven
yeah thank you kevin so um yeah about
god driven
um i think the name already says quite a
lot
so we met we help companies to become
data driven and like kevin already
showed
that's also how we get involved with
interfood
we do we have four pillars as we say one
of them is that we do uh like
organizations more about strategy help
help companies define how to become data
driven what the different parts of this
are what the journey is
uh the second pillar that's where i'm
involved mostly in the third pillar it's
building data applications so data
platforms we have a data platform
proposition
but also the ai application so it's the
analytics platform for the machine
learning engineering but also
implementing the use case themselves so
the ai and the data science
uh thirdly with training um so if you
like what we do definitely check out our
training curriculum um what we believe
were big believers on the military but
we also believe you can only become
really good in something if you also can
explain it to other people
so that's why we do training and finally
we have the managed part
in case of one of our clients they if
they have an updated platform or a ai
application
we help them manage this applications
so this is us this is the
companies
and now we'll start with a small
video
showing
the wisdom of the crowd application
like i said after we're gonna show how
we get to this the first video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kevin over to you
yeah thanks gore so that was indeed a
video of the of the end product a a
mobile app that tries to connect all of
the wisdom of of our traders globally
and actually tries to distill
information from that and we actually
now go over the concept of wisdom of the
crowd
and how we feel that it connects to uh
to the purpose that we have
so within the food we believe in
together for better and that means a
couple of things to us for instance that
we give all of our employees a voice
that we try to to play to win in teams
so that we actually kind of interpret
that voice together and learn from it
and that we openly share that feedback
and as you already saw in the video that
means something about our competitive
edge in the company
and the underlying business that we try
to pursue
so in derry that could for instance mean
that we want to have a vision on what
the price movement will be in a certain
market
so what does the wisdom of the crowd
actually tell us about such a vision
well it's a very old theory and i
believe well at least some people say it
was aristotle
that states that a group can make a
better prediction than an individual
now to fellow statisticians this is not
new but we hope to show a cool
application of what this looks like in a
company so we're trying to amplify the
human intelligence that we have
throughout the organization
with with an ai model and that's what
we're what we go into deeper in our
session
oh and that will be according to this
outline core
we'll start first with the data science
uh we're gonna go uh show a little bit
of code so uh i think it's fun to have
some code in the slides always make a
little technical after that we show the
data pipeline pipeline i think it's good
to know the the system that
we we have in which we do the data
science and finally we come back to user
interfaces which was the app that we
just saw in the video
um so first the data science
and i think
kevin will explain the the model
yeah so the underlying goals as i
already mentioned kind of to cater that
vision of together for better are that
we want to do a couple of things with
the information that we gather for r2
organization
so firstly we use what we call the
wisdom so some sort of average estimate
of all all individual
forecasts and to try to quantify
uncertainty using those individual
estimates that means that we can
challenge our decision making at the
senior management level and it also
means that we get a better view and a
better understanding of risk and return
then comes the novelty which aristotle
didn't think about yet is that we want
to under or overweight participants that
consistently under or over perform
and that applies two things firstly that
everyone can participate and learn
without downside to the group so if you
don't have a particular strong vision or
strong performance somewhere in a
certain market that's okay you can learn
and secondly we will use the group
weighted average because we believe that
that might improve the simple average
and this is of course where the model
training comes in
so 4th century bc theory meets 21st
century technology
yes thank you um
so the the model we have i'm going to
show them in a moment this consists of
five steps
um and so what we do is we're trying to
uh predict the price movements uh for 12
product market combinations so we have
for example the americas europe asia and
they have different type of dairy
products i don't know all of them but
you can imagine like if the milk powder
maybe have some kind of cheese and for
all those different combinations uh
we're gonna look we're gonna try to find
the the price movement
and this is done weekly so the app opens
weekly and people provide input
weekly
and what we do then we have two parts we
do first the training
and then finally we do the prediction uh
which looks ahead right
to
the price movement
the trading part considers still three
steps our first one is the ranking
um so we take we rank the estimates
based on the absolute difference with
the truth
and we do this for every partitioned
product market time combination
um and this is a skill invariant so this
is the same for every product market
combination
then secondly we uh make this rank a
value between zero one where in this
case the uh one is if you're the best um
performing or you have the closest
estimate
um and uh always a person will have at
least a little weight so nobody gets
zero and this goes back to everybody has
a voice so we always give some voice to
everyone
um but in general of course people want
to get higher rank and higher in this
case higher score means that you are
closer to the actual price
um and then thirdly we smooth this over
time we take some average over time
and you can currently we simply have a
moving window where you take the average
but you could also change this to for
example an expense potential smoother
which takes the more recent estimates
give them a higher weight than the the
not so recent
estimates now at the moment uh the the
app opens so we have this already done
this training and people give their
expectations for price movements
uh for the coming weeks
uh then we have to uh we're gonna take
those together and what we do first is
we normalize the beliefs
into weights
so for example not everybody always
gives their expectations and to account
for these kind of things we make sure we
say okay everybody who gave their
expectations take those all together and
then normalize the the beliefs to await
and finally if you don't take those
weights and the actual expectations
uh you get your weight at average which
is the wisdom
um i'm gonna have a look right now in
the chat we're gonna go to the codes
uh if somebody already has a question
then maybe now's a few moments
if not i'm just gonna continue
[Music]
all right let's continue
so um here's the codes um like i said
first step was the ranking and this is
done in line 30. um so if we take the
target the target is the um is the
difference between the
expected price and the actual price as
you can see we take the absolute and
then we take the rank
uh so in my opinion quite
straightforward to read write and then
on line 43 we apply this for the market
protocol horizon and period combination
so we do this for all the traders right
all the traders get a rank from one to n
where n capital n is the number of
traders
then in the second step we do the
normalization of the rank so we inverse
a bit by using the shape which is uh n
but we make sure that if you get the uh
so the highest like the rank number one
which is the best rank becomes weight
number one but if you had rank number n
then you get the weight one divided by n
that's what line 57 does
and we again do this for the more market
product horizon and period combination
so that's the second step and then the
third step is this is this moving over
time right so we
do we do this every week every week the
app opens
and then we every week you get a certain
belief
and then we smooth this over time so as
you can see right now we simply have a
rolling window we take the mean but you
can also do the exponential smoothing
here
and this is the thing you do product
market horizon and trade id so you do
this over for one trader over the
different periods uh so these three
things together are the training
uh then we go over to the prediction
and like i said in the case of the
prediction sometimes everybody gives an
estimate
um so we have to normalize the beliefs
into weight that's what we do in line 88
where we take the weight of the
individual ways and divided by the sun
and we do this for every market product
horizon and period combination again
and finally if you combine the weights
with the estimates
and you also do this for the product
market in rise in the period combination
you sum them
you get
you get to your
weighted average
i got a question it looks like a
weighted ensemble through the time is
that correct
i have to think about the ensemble uh
part but you could say indeed that the
uh that every
uh trader in this case could be one
model in some way and then you combine
them indeed together
which makes it an ensemble model uh and
then so i think the the answer to your
question is yes
all right so this was the uh the science
and um what i want to emphasize here is
again about the demystifying data what i
think is really cool that we have here a
model which is written down in clear
mathematical equations and we also baked
in that everybody has a full voice so i
want to emphasize is every every uh
trader gets at least the one over n
weight
um and this is how we translate such a
vision such a
mission
into uh into cults
um and the second part
uh i wanna show you the data pipeline
for you to know a little bit more of the
context that we use
um so we have a data platform uh and
typically in a data platform or data
pipeline is that you start on the left
and that's with the ingestion of data
right so we have the data capture the
operational data
then we put this in a data lake
and it's called a lake house because we
also have the sql server and the sql
server is there for practical reason
because quite a most of our
consumption uh reads from this sql
server like tableau or an app
xdml workspace where we do the machine
learning that's what we just saw in the
previous slide data science that
directly that that one directly reads
from the lake
um so if you go back to the flow from a
user perspective
uh oh wait i forgot on top of the lake
we use dbt
to do the transformations
uh but if you look at the flow from a
user perspective uh somebody is gonna go
look at the app right the app asks hey
what's your expectation for this product
market combination and this is a
separate an app developed separately
and the back end of this app um the
front that's developed in aws is hosted
abs but the back end is in an sql server
which is uh outside the data platform
and so then that's where we store the
data at first
then we ingest the data into our data
lake and then you can consume it into
our machine learner workspace and to for
an example the thing we do in the middle
in the data lake is for example to make
sure that we do the salute conversions
right like use dollar to euros or metric
conversions and we account for all those
kind of things
and there's a couple feedback loops
so one of them is that we get the
estimates back into the
into the lake so we can use them in the
dashboard but also we actually supply
some data to the app as well which reads
from the sql server
um
it's quite a lot a big slide
i can do a separate talk on this alone
but i want to highlight one one uh small
thing here is uh we did a computer
contribution back to dvt spark
and we were able to write directly from
our lake to the sql server which is i
think a nice technical solution that we
don't have to put another tool in there
to move data from a storage to the sql
server
kevin can you
talk us to the user interface
yeah so as you already noticed that
there is there's this user perspective
that was also just discussed in there in
the pipeline and that really is this
application that interfaces towards the
traders
and it is it's based on our sso login it
has the current market information for
uh for the trader to see and then to
decide where where to put the vision for
the coming weeks
it has product information on the
different product market combinations so
it's really detailed what we exactly
expect
and you can you can have your user
settings on various uh volutes of
various affects and various unit of
measures
such that you can actually fill in the
price movement in the kind of setting
that you you always
think about every every day of the week
as a trader whether you are in the u.s
or in asia or in europe
oh thank you
so this um
this was the wisdom of the crowd i hope
you enjoy the talk
and uh like i said already i think uh it
was a nice example how we trade
translated this uh
this vision of uh together for better to
attend your data products
and
um yeah thanks for being here if there's
any questions please let us know
let's see in the chat uh stephen the
first question we already answered and
uh tom indeed i think uh like this
moving over time indeed helps to make
sure that we don't uh that it doesn't go
up and down too much oh yes
yeah we've got we've got a couple more
minutes i was going to ask if you
answered the test question from tom yet
yeah to me that ensures embedding inert
chef market
changes rapidly then way
which previously assigned to people can
lead you astray yeah that's that's
correct
so like smoothing over time you
stabilize the model in some way
um and that's exactly what something
exactly and also another thing to
mention is if the market changes rapidly
that does not necessarily mean that the
the traders that had high weight are now
performing less maybe they can also
actually anticipate on that rapid market
movement so there's a distinction
between smoothing that we do
over time within a trader and the
average that we take across traders
and both try to accommodate for the fact
that we can we can follow the market uh
as well as possible
all right you guys uh
thank you very much for being a part of
the conference this year
you know just wait wish you well for the
rest of your day and weekend
thank you steven thank you for hosting
us